our elites are always telling you how
progressive they are they tout their
commitment to diversity they fret about
global warming they're up for any new
bathroom rule you can think of as long
as it sounds modern they're classic cool
moms basically eager to show off their
open minds but their liberalism ends at
the water's edge when it comes to China
our greatest rival American elites bow
deeply to the elderly fascists who run
that country when the Chinese say jump a
ruling class has only one question how
high considered gap the proudly liberal
clothing outfit this spring gap pulled a
t-shirt from all of its stores worldwide
because that shirt featured an outline
of China the image did not include
Taiwan or an obscure group of disputed
islands in the South China Sea and
Beijing complained about that gap
immediately destroyed the t-shirts then
the company issued a groveling press
release quote Gap Inc respects the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
China we failed to reflect the correct
map of China in other words I'm sorry
for being naughty most honorable sir
gasp ROM gap promised it would never
happen again that's just one of many
examples in January Marriott apologized
for listing Tibet Taiwan and Hong Kong
and Macau as separate countries on an
email questionnaire then Marriott fired
an employee who liked to tweet about it
Mary it's obsequious apology to China's
dictator says at all quote some
associates don't understand or take
seriously enough the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of China clearly
written by the Chinese offending China
is now a fireable offense in this
country American Express Citibank
Goldman Sachs they all agree those
companies have all changed online
content to eliminate suggestions that
Taiwan and China are separate countries
even though of course they are separate
countries the Chinese insist American
companies lie about that and so they do
Hollywood's been doing it for years the
movie studios have been obedient to
China's rulers probably for more than a
decade asked Richard Gere the actor he
says now he has trouble getting work
because his views on Tibet offend
Chinese officials in 2016 the movie
Doctor Strange producers cast a white
woman in the role of a Tibetan character
why they do that doesn't sound like the
diversity doctrine at work it's not but
they did it anyway why well the
screenwriter explained that casting an
ethnic Tibetan would make China mad so
they couldn't in 2012
remake of Red Dawn changed the bad guy
from China to North Korea why you know
because they didn't want to offend
Beijing how eager are American elites to
do the bidding of their Chinese masters
ask yourself this whatever happens at
the Dali Lama remember him he used to be
a hero to Americans especially American
liberals they loved him you almost never
hear his name anymore it turns out the
Chinese government doesn't like him for
his human rights activism so under
pressure from the Chinese government his
appearances by the Dalai Lama have been
cancelled around the world including
shamefully in this country the Dalai
Lama may be a great moral leader but
China pays the bills
Frank wolf is a rare former member of
Congress who has been sounding the alarm
on China for a very long time and he
joins us now congressman I'm grateful to
have you you really are one of the very
few former members of Congress who is
pointing out the human rights abuses in
China and is willing to say what is true
which is they're bullying us why is that
why aren't more saying well I don't know
Tucker but you're right I mean 142
Tibetan monks and nuns supported
kerosene on the body set themselves
aflame
there are Wiggy rows llem joven
thousands thousands being taken away to
detention camps Catholic Bishops right
now right right now as long as lumps are
being rounded up thousands many many
many thousands in the in detention camp
almost like Stalinist camps and catholic
bishops missing to Kashyap Chris Smith
took holy communion for a bishop so he
has never been seen again Protestant
pastors are being arrested I mean it is
it is as bad today's has ever been since
that's now and you're exactly right I
mean Richard Gere will never make
another another movie AMC has been sold
to the Chinese other studios have been
sold and they censor you and then they
sense you besaid if you run that Richard
Gere will never be in a major movie so
without naming names because this is a
very small city and you've been here for
a long time but looking out across the
city you know a lot of lobbyists laden
served in Congress what percentage would
you say are on the payroll in some way
with China well I'll say some names I
mean one of the bigger firms in town
Squires Patton Boggs they represent the
Chinese government they also represent
Bashi
the indicted war criminal from Sudan
who's been indicted for genocide squires
Pam Boggs they represent them so would
you say that many different lobbying
outfits PR firms in Washington in some
way take money from the Chinese and yes
they they do what's just interesting
during the 80s when I got elected when
Ronald Reagan was here no company no PR
firm no law firm would have ever
represents the Soviet Union and now so
many are representing chummy force
choirs patton boggs to represent Basheer
the President of Sudan who is an
indicted war criminal for a genocide
what took place in Darfur so the
standards in a stand of totally do you
think that that may be connected to the
fact that you almost you hear a lot
about Russia but you never hear anything
about China's human rights abuses
they're connected the the the human
rights abuses and religious lack of
religious freedom is worse today in
China than it's been since the days of
now and don't forget President Xi has
now appointed himself president for life
it is terrible that's why I can't
understand the very fact that thousands
of Muslim kids are being taken away I
had a Muslim woman come by my office
about two months ago thirty five of her
grandchildren have been taken and put in
these the attention kids I urge you to
google when this show we're doing
actually it just could mean next week
we're gonna do a segment on Chinese
human rights abuses and you would think
that American liberals would care but
they don't you do and I appreciate it
congressman thank you for coming on
thank you great to see you think